this is because the unbeatable but
you're say because open up the top this
thing needs to get put into position so
what is this
yeah in this guy you can say that on the
bottom is this sir - stop it slipping up
this is okay and then you'll be okay
yeah that's fair if if for any reason
you want to make it higher than what it
is
you can make a limit higher than this by
unwinding yup is that sorry there's a
little clog there as in this hammer
comes out though you might uh I don't
know you'll be up on the stage so maybe
you will want to know how they go okay
so you probably need that's as high as
it goes good so you probably okay yeah
the next thing you want is the mic okay
you got to be careful with this
unfortunately this some this silvery
color it's sort of coming out to it but
we don't hold it by their honor
okay now in the bottom of it there's a
little port that you can put this cable
you it can only go in one way so don't
worry you can't screw that up so it goes
in and
your other end of the cave or like so
just fits in viang at the bottom of so
you know there's like a little marker
and that points to you so you guys okay
now you're basically done just gonna
take this off because they'll be easier
for me to show you when you want to the
last basic thing that you need to do is
when you've got the mic plugged in
you'll know that it's on because there's
a little set of lights that's here on
the front which I'm not on right now
okay so what you need to do is get the
iPad unlock it sorry
and open the open the camera app okay I
don't know if it'll start defaulted on
movie or still but that's where you can
change it at the moment it's a movie
because you know it's got that recording
icon now to turn the mic on you actually
just have to start recording okay so
you'll know you're recording because
that's flashing and the time it is going
okay once you stop it you've noticed
optic the mic is still on which is
exactly what you want because now on the
front here you can see these tiny pin
lights here you want to make them like a
sensitive as possible so this button
here hold it down if you're hundred that
long enough the lights will turn orange
okay and then you want to turn it I
think it's clockwise until all of the
lights are on
okay if you turn the other way all the
lights would go off and then it won't
pick up as much okay so I'm turning all
the way up you want to have the mic
obviously as far forward as possible but
not so far forward that your arm you're
bending that cable because I've only got
the one
yeah